welcome back to las vegas now time to
focus on our health as we talk about flu
shots because even though it may not
feel like it winter is around the corner
and with it is also flu season jc talked
with a specialist from southwest medical
associates who is sponsoring this
segment for more information
now so let's talk about the flu shot
that's right here today who should be
getting the flu shot that's a great
question you know the recommendation
with very rare exceptions that everybody
six months and older should heavily
being considering getting the flu shot
right now
so essential workers should they be
stepping in there and getting a flu shot
this year definitely our essential
workers including healthcare personnel
those who work or even reside in
long-term care facilities anybody who's
out there in the public and part of
critical infrastructure as well as those
people who may be at increased risk
younger children elderly patients older
than 65 anybody with chronic medical
conditions like diabetes or high blood
pressure all those people are at higher
risk and should definitely be getting
vaccinated
so getting the flu shot will this help
ease the pandemic at all
you know the flu vaccine is a whole
pandemic of its its own you know it
won't have any impact on covid19
unfortunately but it will help protect
each of our community members as well as
our healthcare infrastructure from
avoiding potentially scarce resources we
know what that was like unfortunately
when the pandemic first hit and anything
that we can do to keep ourselves healthy
and to really keep those resources there
for those patients who need them is
definitely a win so that goes definitely
in in getting the flu vaccine and i'm
just looking at this from afar but it
feels like last year's numbers the flu
numbers were much lower because people
were still indoors not doing as much
this year more people are going out are
we expecting a bigger flu season this
year
the cdc does foresee that we're gonna
have just as large of a flu season as we
have in the past even though we've had
some quarantine and stay-at-home
measures one of the downfalls of stay at
home and sheltering in place is that
many patients have avoided or not had
access to their preventative health care
including immunizations so as we go into
this flu season mixed with that of the
cobalt 19 pandemic season it's so
important that we're thinking about
protecting ourselves
when should we start thinking about
getting the flu shot
now is the perfect time to get it and
i'm glad that you asked generally
september or october is the ideal time
to be getting your vaccine knowing that
it can take two weeks for that vaccine
to be active to protect yourself and
making sure you get it before those
cases start to come into the community
is so important and you guys are making
it much easier to get the flu shot this
year tell us about some of the upcoming
flu shot events that you have so we're
very excited on saturday september 18th
to be having our first drive-through flu
shot clinic that'll be at our tenea
healthcare center at 2704 north to
nayaway from eight a.m to noon and we're
also going to have a second drive
through flu shot clinic on saturday
september 25th at our eastern healthcare
center on 4475 southeastern also from 8
am to noon of note both of those
locations will also be offering the
covered vaccine though that will be
indoors not drive through
and the first hundred cars at each event
will receive a free biggest golden
knights gift and chance will be dropping
by two
we want to thank southwest medical
associates for sponsoring this segment
if you need their help they do have
locations across southern nevada give
them a call for more information at
702-877-5199
we'll be right